mes collègues à ce que vous voyez une
innocente de récupération par les
féministes des affaires qui défraient la
chronique depuis quelques semaines et où
en partant de semble-t-il d'affaires de
harcèlement de viol qui sont
effectivement authentique et grave veut
un petit peu culpabilisé l'ensemble de
la gente masculine
il ya deux choses il ya une mise en
ordre de dérivés d'excès qui existait
depuis le droit de cuissage
c'est une énorme occidentales elles
étaient déjà installés dans nos
civilisations
mais dans un pays chrétien le droit de
cuissage étaient des choses officielles
un ordi c'est celle de la promotion
canapé donc on est aujourd'hui dans une
situation de droit de cuissage promotion
canapé alors là où on voudra bémol ce
qu' il y a aussi des individus hommes ou
femmes qui sont pour la promotion canapé
il ya aussi les femmes qui ont appelé à
cette dérive parce qu'elle souhaitait
alors c'est horrible elle savait qu'elle
n'avait pas le choix
mais elles ont souvent provoqué ou
favoriser ce genre de dérive donc moment
donné on ne sait plus où on en est moi
je veux bien je voudrais qu'on soit
aussi sévère avec ces femmes qui sont
officiellement et ouvertement soumises
et emilie qui sont les femmes qui
portent le voile en république française
laïque
je voudrais que y ait des hashtags
balances ton islamistes balance l'homme
qui dit voile toute la journée et qui
t'oblige à sortir dans la rue en
république française avec voilà on en
croise de plus en plus pas partout on a
l'impression que quelquefois ils ne sont
pas nombreux je connais des territoires
où elles sont très nombreuses
donc je suis totalement solidaire des
fables qui sont harcelés sexuellement et
je suis totalement solidaire des
citoyennes françaises aidées des femmes
qui vivent en france et qui en
république française sont obligés de
subir cette mobilisation féminine et qui
ne suscite que finalement à part les
problèmes de l'intégrale que peu
d'émotion de la part de féministes voilà
j'aimerais bien que la part soit égale
pour les deux